the investigation into the deadly mass
shooting at one of the nation's largest
breweries is now focused on a home on
Milwaukee's North Side a heavy police
presence was reported there overnight
police say a 51 year old employee killed
five co workers before taking his own
life
SWAT teams quickly responded to the
sprawling Molson Coors complex yesterday
after receiving emergency calls Dean
Reynolds has more from Milwaukee at 2:08
p.m. yesterday police and fire rescue
from Milwaukee and surrounding areas
rushed to the Molson Coors plant
following reports of an active shooter
wearing bulletproof vests and heavily
armed they FBI and ATF agents stormed
the campus searching for the gunman
nearby schools and businesses were
placed on lockdown as dozens of officers
cleared each building on a campus where
around a thousand people work we're all
pretty scared I mean we were watching
the live streams on TV try and see what
was going on outside because we can see
anything about five hours after the
shooting began investigators confirmed
the gunmen killed five people before
turning the gun on himself this is an
unspeakable tragedy for our city this is
a community tragedy and as we grieve for
these families we must remember the
sacrifices that they made as police
cleared the scene employees on the
campus were allowed to leave one by one
to reunite with their families I
wouldn't go on to talk to this guy there
it was relieving me I'd be one of them
guys yeah I know that for a fact because
I would have walked right into what was
going on Randy Chenoweth has worked as a
utilities operator at the plant for 42
years he says he was in an office just
15 to 20 feet away from the gunshots
during his shift change I know some of
the victims and I really feel for the
families pray for you it's all I can
really do Dean Reynolds reporting from
Milwaukee Forrest Dean thank you very
much